my name is Margaret killer and i am the
african development bank representative
in Liberia I belong to the council on
fragile stainless I would like to talk
about my vision for fragile states over
the next 20 year period looking at the
long term we are in a world in crisis at
the moment and fragile states are
already in their own set of crises and
when there is the kind of crisis that
were experiencing in the financial
sector in the economic sector as a
global crisis fragile states will tend
to suffer the most so my vision my
proposal for the next 20 years to help
fragile states come out of fragility is
to look at how the stain the partners
will function in a new relationship and
that relationship is one where the state
will be our basically the policymaker
the regulator of a business environment
that will help solve kinds of problems
that we experience over the Arab Spring
such as high youth unemployment given
the fact that this group of countries
have a very big large youthful
population so I see the role of the OECD
traditional donors given the current
crisis that they themselves are going
through I see that group
as pushing more the knowledge agenda
giving advice in the kinds of areas that
they themselves are strong in so that
institutions in fragile states will be
built I see the second group of partners
being the bricks the emerging economies
that have a lot of capital to invest as
the group that will invest in
infrastructure be it roads energy
technology telecommunications water
those kinds of investments that will
assist the government in providing basic
services to the people and will enable
the business business set services to be
provided so investors can actually come
into the countries to invest especially
in the extractive industries especially
in manufacturing in those kinds of areas
that federal state need to grow their
economies the government then else a
regulator policy maker and a regulator
will promote skills training for young
people many many young people who have
come out of conflict without much
education without literacy without the
kinds of technical and vocational skills
that they need in society this is my
vision for the finals it's over the next